[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight for the past week all of us have
seen chaos engulf our beloved country
the violence and the destruction have
been so overwhelming so shocking and
awful and vivid on the screen that it's
been hard to think clearly about what's
going on most of us haven't been able to
step back far enough to ask even the
obvious questions the most obvious of
course is what is this really about what
do the mobs want
well the thugs looting the Apple store
can't answer that question they have no
idea they just want free iPads but what
about Apple itself and the rest of
Corporate America which is
enthusiastically supporting the rioters
what about members of Congress the media
figures the celebrities that tech Titans
all of whom are cheering this on what do
they want out of it well they haven't
said that's the central mystery now
suddenly it is obvious it should have
been obvious the first day this is about
Donald Trump of course it is we just
couldn't see it for normal people Donald
Trump is a president you may like him
you may not like him but either way
there will be another president at some
point and we will move on as we always
have
but for Donald Trump's enemies there is
nothing else everything is about Trump
everything Donald Trump defines their
friendships their careers their
marriages Donald Trump affects how they
raise their children
Trump occupies the very center of their
lives as long as Donald Trump remains in
the White House they feel powerless and
diminished and panicked they cannot be
happy in everything they do their
overriding goal is to remove Donald
Trump from office and that's exactly
what they're trying to do now that's
what these riots are about the most
privileged in our society are using the
most desperate in our society to seize
power from everyone else got that that's
the nub of it the most privileged are
using the most desperate to seize power
from the rest of us they are not seeking
racial justice if they were seeking
racial justice they wouldn't be
denouncing their fellow Americans for
their race which they are it has nothing
to
do with it what they are seeking is
total control of the country and it goes
that saying that none of this has
anything to do with George Floyd shame
on those who pretended that it did those
who fell for the lie and those who knew
better but played along because they are
cowards
there are many of those you knew who
they are and someday we will look back
on all of them with contempt meanwhile
the many promoters of this chaos remain
clear-eyed they are not lying to
themselves they never do they know
exactly what's going on and they know
what they hope to achieve by it with
every night of rioting they grow bolder
now they are openly defending violence
on television people worried about the
protesters and looters and it's just
people who are frustrated they are
frustrated and they are angry and they
are out there and they're upset you
shouldn't be taking televisions but I
can't tell people how to react to this
I'm proud of the protests and I think
it's part of the tradition of New York
the violence is bad reprehensible should
be condemned but it is not the
overwhelming picture in New York
destroying property which can be
replaced is not violence to many see the
protests as the problem please show me
where it says that protests are supposed
to be polite and peaceful you're crushed
by this you can't believe it's happening
to your country but for the people you
just saw the real problem is that the
rioting in some rare places is being
stopped by police and their aim is to
fix that they would like to eliminate
all law enforcement for good today
Democrats in Dallas took down the statue
of a Texas Ranger from the terminal at
Love Field that had stood in the airport
for more than 50 years but Texas Rangers
are cops and cops must be removed even
when they're made of bronze meanwhile
the Lego toy company has ceased
marketing sets that contain plastic
police officers apparently they're too
dangerous for our children and so on so
much of this going on right now if it
all seems like yet another episode of
the silly and fleeting hysteria that
sometimes grips our culture out of
nowhere usually in lulls in the news
cycle you should know that it's not that
this is entirely real
it is being pushed by serious people and
they are deadly serious about it last
night for example Brian Fallon who is
the press secretary of the Hillary
Clinton for president campaign in the
last election cycle tweeted quote defund
the police congressman Rasheeda Talib
agrees expect more members of Congress
to agree soon in some places they're not
talking they're acting Steve Fletcher
represents the Third Ward in Minneapolis
he's on the City Council there by this
week his city had been completely
scorched by riots at least 66 businesses
were utterly destroyed by fire 300 more
had been vandalized or looted Fletcher
didn't even mention that instead he
attacked the city's police department
for trying to contain the violence quote
several of us on the council are working
on finding out what it would take to
disband the Minneapolis Police
Department end quote
you'd think people in the city would be
shocked by that but at least on the city
council everyone else nodded their
approval in the Ninth Ward Councilwoman
Alondra Aquino tweeted this yesterday
quote the Minneapolis Police Department
is not Reforma boleyn
according to city councilman Fletcher
all nine members of the City Council are
now considering getting rid of the
Minneapolis Police Department hard to
believe but it's not just there in the
city of Los Angeles Mayor Eric Garcetti
looks out across the worst rioting in
this nation's second-largest city in a
generation in almost 30 years his
conclusion we need far fewer police it
could have been better if they hadn't
been there Garcetti has announced he's
going to cut funding for law enforcement
she didn't know we will not be
increasing our police budget how can we
at this moment our city through our city
administrative officer identified 250
million dollars in cuts so we could
invest in jobs in health in education
and in healing and that those dollars
need to be focused on our black
community here in Los Angeles as well as
communities of color and women and
people who have been left behind for too
long and will this involve cuts yes of
course to every department including the
police
Department when Democrats across the
country start saying the same thing at
the same time you can be certain there's
a reason for it and in this case they
clearly mean it according to the
president of the LA Police Commission
city officials may cut a hundred and
fifty million dollars from the LAPD that
would be more than ten percent of the
entire police budget in the wake of
rioting in New York
48 separate Democratic candidates and
then we're including in that the
Manhattan district attorney signed a
letter demanding a 1 billion dollar cut
to the budget of the NYPD why are they
doing this there are reasons not the
ones they tell you they tell you it's
about racism they tell you that cops are
racist and must be reined in most
Americans don't agree with that that's
not the experience they have in fact
police departments are one of the most
trusted institutions in the country
according to Gallup polling last year 53
percent of Americans said they had a
great deal or quite a lot of confidence
in the police that was far more
confidence that they had in almost any
other institution banks religious
leaders the health care system
television news public schools corporate
American newspapers name one all of
those were stuck below 40% how many
Americans trusted Congress 11% and in
fact most African Americans still
support the police a 2016 Pew poll found
that 55 percent of African Americans had
confidence in the police within their
own communities in other words cops they
actually knew and dealt with they had
confidence but study by the Bureau of
Justice Statistics from 2011 found that
among those who called the police for
help more than 90 percent of African
Americans felt the police behaved
properly so what would happen if we got
rid of the police of all lorem law
enforcement how would Americans feel if
they actually defunded the police well
terrified mostly that's how we would
feel things would fall apart
instantly it would take hours don't
believe it
spend an afternoon in a place with no
law enforcement and see what you think
talk to anyone who was in Baghdad at the
height of the Iraq war
ask anyone who stayed in New Orleans for
Katrina their memories will be fresh
they'll never forget what they saw
here's the key eliminating the police
does not mean eliminating Authority
there is always a thority there are no
vacuums in nature the only question is
whether or not the authority is
legitimate whether or not the authority
is accountable whether or not you can do
anything if the authority abuses its
power in the absence of law enforcement
the answer is no it means thugs are in
charge the most violent people have the
most power they can do whatever they
want to you that's the reality everyone
obeys the violent people or they get
hurt the mob literally rules that
probably sounds like a nightmare to you
because it is but the people pushing
this idea don't see it as scary because
they don't fear the mob because they
control the mob that's the key and they
see violence as an instrument of their
political power with mobs in the streets
that they control they will finally get
what they want Donald Trump out of
office and a hammerlock on the country
that's what's happening